- Hi everyone, Sal Khan
here from Khan Academy.
Welcome to the Homeroom live stream,
we've had a little bit of a hiatus
so it's good to see all of y'all again.
We have a really exciting guest today,
Neel Kashkari who is the president of
the Federal Reserve Bank of Minneapolis
so we're gonna be able to
talk a lot about the economy
and Federal Reserve and
everything that's going on.
Before we can jump into that
I will give a couple of
my standard reminders.
First of all, a reminder that Khan Academy
is a not-for-profit and we can
only exist through donations
from folks like yourself, if
you're in a position to do so.
[Sal] So please think about
going to khanacademy.org/donate
and donations of all size,
make a huge, huge difference.
I also wanna give a special shout out
to several organizations that
have stepped up especially during COVID.
When they realized that Khan Academy
was being even more leaned on
and we were running at a deficit,
we're continuing to run
a deficit in the 2021
but special thanks to
Bank of America, AT&T,
Google.org, Novartis,
Fastly and General Motors
for stepping up in a
big way to ensure that
we could continue to
serve tens of millions
of learners around the world
through the crisis and beyond.
And then the last reminder
is that you can get a version
of this a live stream in podcast format
however you get your podcasts
at Homeroom With Sal the podcast.
So with that I'm really excited
to introduce Neel Kashkari.
Neel, thanks for joining.
- Thanks for having me Sal,
it's great to be with you.
- So I've been dying to
have this conversation
since you first came on my radar
obviously during the 2010 financial crisis
you were very involved there.
Then you had a really fascinating,
I guess career where
now you're the president
of the Federal Reserve
Bank of Minneapolis.
So let's start in the present,
maybe a good place to start
is I think most people
have a general idea that
there's something called
the Federal Reserve and affects
things like monetary policy
and interest rates.
And then you have these regional banks
of which you're a
president of one of them.
How does all of this work?
What is the overall charter
of the Federal Reserve
and what is kind of the
role of the regional banks?
- Well, thanks for starting at that Sal.
So in 1913, Congress created
the Federal Reserve System
which is the nation's central bank
and very simply our job [Indistinct]
interest rates up and down
to try to manage the ups
and downs of the US economy.
But Congress were unique in 1913
they said they don't want the
central bank simply housed
in Washington, D.C in the capital,
they wanted it distributed
around the country.
So they created 12 independent
Federal Reserve Banks,
the ninth of which is the Minneapolis Fed.
So our job was to cover
this region, Minnesota
North and South Dakota,
Montana, part of Michigan,
part of Wisconsin and the
12th Federal Reserve Bank is
the Federal Reserve Bank of San Francisco
which covers a huge area that
wasn't very populated in 1913
but today it's really populated.
The whole Western third of United States
is effectively covered
by the San Francisco Fed.
So our jobs are, we do a bunch of things,
we regulate banks, we provide cash.
If you go to the ATM and need
to take out a hundred dollars
that cash would have started
out in a Federal Reserve Bank
but we also understand what's
happening in the economy
and participate in the process
where we set interest rates for the nation
to try to achieve this
economy that is growing,
not overheating but
also not limping along.
- And for anyone who's curious
we have actually many Khan Academy videos
on exactly the mechanism
by how the Federal Reserve
can insert money and
affect interest rates.
It's a little bit complex,
but definitely understandable,
so I encourage people to check that out
if you're really curious about that
and Neel what is on a day-to-day basis,
what are kind of the types of questions
that you think about and are
kind of within your charter?
I was just thinking about right now.
- Well, right now I
mean, we have two goals
fundamental goals that
Congress has given us
to achieve that stable economy.
One is low inflation that
we define as 2% inflation,
and one is maximum employment
as many Americans household are working
and participating in our economy.
And we normally think these
two goals are intention
and we're trading them off of each other.
So if the economy is really strong
and businesses have to
compete to find workers
the unemployment rate will go down,
wages will go up and
that'll lead to inflation
and then we'll have to raise it
through straits to level that off.
Well, so that's where a
lot of our time is focused,
Is are we at maximum employment?
What's happening in the economy?
Is there spare capacity?
Now with the pandemic, you
know before the pandemic hit,
unemployment rate in America was quite low
at around three and half percent
but then the pandemic hit
and millions of Americans lost their jobs.
So the past year my
job has been different,
for the past year I've
spent a lot of time talking
to the best health experts in the country
to understand where is
the virus likely going?
How long is this crisis going to endure?
And then what does that mean
for our economic recovery?
So we can achieve maximum employment
and put Americans back to work.
- And what do you think are the levers
at the Federal Reserves?
What are the levers that you all disposal?
There's this notion of
lowering interest rates
as much as possible and
some of the mechanics
of that is essentially you're able
to increase the aggregate
Federal Reserve balance sheet
insert more cash and so
interest rates can come down,
but it seems like right now
we're already getting close
to the floor there.
Are there other levers that
the Federal Reserve can do
or is it really more dependent
on the federal government
to do more fiscal stimulus at this point?
- Yeah, great, great question.
So we are doing a lot,
we're using our tools
I wouldn't say that
they're fully maxed out
but we're using them aggressively.
And by lowering interest
rates, we'll make it cheaper
for a family to get a
mortgage to buy a house
or for a business to get a
loan to go build a factory.
That's how we stimulate the economy.
So our foot on the floor right
now will be trying to give
a lot of stimulus to get
the economy moving again.
And you're right.
So now the key really is
the fiscal policy makers
or the Congress to continue
to step up to support
the millions of Americans
have lost their jobs
and then thousands and
thousands of small businesses.
Many have already shuttered,
but many are teetering
because their businesses
have been impacted by this.
And so the COVID crisis is an
example where monetary policy
and fiscal policy can
compliment each other
to support the American people until
we get the pandemic behind us.
- And one question related to that,
that I've been having a dinner parties
and I don't know the right answer to it.
I don't think there's a clear answer.
All of the monetary policy
and the monetary stimulus
has been going in
it makes all the sense in the world to me
for all the reasons you just said
especially in service sector, retail jobs,
travel airlines they are suffering.
If you can lower interest rates,
it can stimulate some demand,
people can continue to
invest in certain areas,
the cost of buying certain things
will go down, et cetera, et cetera.
But it does seem like
there's this divergence,
people have talked about the
K-shaped economic recovery,
where to some degree those
who do have access to capital
even people who own houses,
when interest rates go down
they can refinance they benefit,
the buyers have more purchasing power
so the house price goes up they benefit,
arguably companies might benefit
and once again, that might have follow
on benefits for many other folks.
But if you use the stock
market out of the stock market
should necessarily be the
high fidelity indicator,
but if you use that, if
you use other indicators
that does look like this
separation that's happened
where those who have some
assets who have access
to kind of resources are doing better,
and the monetary policy isn't
able to necessarily reach
as much those who don't
have as many resources.
- I think that's very fair.
I think the K-shaped recovery is real.
The tech sector is booming, the
companies like in Minnesota,
General Mills is one of our big companies.
They grew up, provide the food
that's on the shelves
in our grocery stores
because we've all stopped
going out to restaurants
and I go to the grocery
store a lot more often.
Companies like General Mills
are doing really well in this pandemic
but then you have the restaurants
and you have the airlines
and you have the hotels
and so I think the
K-shaped recovery is real.
And let's be clear, low interest rates
is not gonna do anything
to help the restaurant
that is closed because
of the pandemic, right?
If they can't have customers come in
because it's not safe,
there's simply nothing
that interest rates are
gonna do to help them,
and that's why we're doing whatever we can
to give the best analysis we have,
encourage our friends in the Congress
or in the executive branch
to provide fiscal support
to people that have been laid off
into those small businesses
where monetary policy
is not gonna be very helpful.
The monetary policy is a blunt instrument
that affects the whole
economy at the same time.
There's no way for us to target it
to one sector or another sector.
- And what's your view there?
I know the Federal Reserve
is an intentionally separate
from the government and it's intended
to be a kind of a non-political entity.
But right now in Washington
you do have a debate
where it looks like the
Biden administration wants
to be more aggressive on the stimulus
while the Republican
members of Congress wanna be
a little bit more conservative.
They also wanna do it
but we're talking about
I think 600 billion versus
well, over a trillion or two
does the Federal Reserve
have a point of view on that?
Or are you allowed to have a
public point of view on that?
- Well, I get asked about that
from elected representatives
from my district all the time
and I always give them
the best advice I can.
I think those kinds of
negotiations generally between
where should be 1 million or
600 billion or 1.4 trillion?
I think we try to stay out
of that because that really
is about the political process
making those decisions.
I think I've been very vocal
and I'll continue to be vocal saying
the job market today in America
is as bad as the worst job market
during the financial crisis.
They have an unemployment
rate of 6.5, 6.7%.
The real unemployment rate is around 10%,
there's a lot of people have
given up looking for work.
So my basic message is
we are nowhere close
to having rebuilt our economy
and putting people back to work,
and so whatever Congress and
the administration choose to do
I would encourage them to
focus on those millions
of Americans that are
still suffering today,
still out of work, they
need more assistance until
we can get this pandemic behind us.
- Yeah, and what you just highlighted
I think is a really important point
'cause a lot of folks don't realize that
the details of how
things like unemployment
how they're calculated really
tell you a lot about things,
because there's a world where
people could get laid off
and as long as they're
continuing to look for work
they're included in the labor pool.
And so they're counted
in the unemployment,
but then if they just
give up at some point,
say yeah, you know what? I'm
just not gonna find a job.
I'm just gonna like live with
my parents or something else.
Then they're not even
counted in the unemployment
so actually you could have this dynamic
but to your point, I guess,
the more stimulus we can do the better.
How concerned if we do
very aggressive stimulus
'cause we talked about earlier
and this is kind of your
classical point of view
is if the federal government
runs huge deficits
in order to provide stimulus all
while interest rates are quite low
that might create a lot of demand
for a limited pool of resources
or capacity or productivity
which could lead to a lot of inflation
which is obviously really
to one of y'all's charter.
How worried are you all
about that right now?
- I'll speak for myself,
I'm not worried about it.
Inflation has been
running low for 10 years
before the pandemic, and
now it's running even lower.
If we had a little bit more inflation
I think we would consider
that to be success
in as achieving our goal of
2% inflation here in Europe.
But something really curious
happened in this pandemic,
those of us who kept our
jobs like you, like me
like many of your viewers here today,
generally speaking,
we're saving more money
'cause we're not going out to restaurants
except we're going to the grocery store.
We're not taking vacations and trips,
we're staying at home.
So the savings rate has gone way up
because people who kept
their jobs are doing fine,
their incomes haven't been cut
and they're saving more money.
So the way the macro-economy works,
if you keep that money in the bank
it ends up flowing back
into the financial markets
and that money is actually
available to financier,
these increased government deficit.
So I do think at some point
we have to get our fiscal house in order,
we have to make tough
choices as a country,
but right now this is like we are at war
and this is in my view war time spending
to defeat the virus, that enemy
and to support our fellow Americans
until we can get through it.
So we have the capacity to do it.
- And I wanna encourage
everyone watching on YouTube
or Facebook, please send your questions.
We're already getting a
lot of great questions
and I'll start with one from
SmartBear on YouTube asking
how do you think the economy
will change in the near future
due to the COVID-19 variants and more?
and I'll extend that, do you
think there's gonna be...
let's hope a year from now,
we're back to some normalcy.
Do you think there's gonna
be structural changes
to the economy because of what
we're going through it with COVID?
- I think that there are
hard to identify right now.
I mean, one example is
we've all figured out,
you figure this out Sal, a long time ago
but we all the rest of us figured out
that you can actually work
remotely very effectively
in many industries and in many
cases, not all, but in many.
And so I would expect
that the use of technology
like this is going to
be permanently higher
than it was before the pandemic.
I don't know, we have 1100
employees in our bank,
all the 50 or 70 of them
are working remotely,
working from home.
I expect the vast majority
to come into the bank
but many structures look
a little bit different
to take advantage of this technology
and provide more flexibility.
It's certainly possible.
Might we travel a little
less for conferences
and do more of them virtually
or in a hybrid format certainly?
So I think that likely
there'll be many changes
that are permanent, that are positive
that are hard to identify
exactly right now.
- Yeah, I actually even heard,
I agree with a lot of that
and I'm fascinated, even at Khan Academy
we're thinking about what's
the right use of office space?
How much travel do we need
to do? Et cetera, et cetera.
But you know, I was entertained
when I read, this was several months ago
that retailers are seeing a lot of sales
of tops, of formal tops
and casual bottoms.
So finally the rest of the world
is starting to dress like I am,
I don't know if you're
wearing jogging pants
below the waist, but I am right now.
So (laughing).
- I'm wearing (mumbles) you can't see
if I'm wearing (mumbles).
(laughing)
- I won't make you validated
but I said, oh, I'm going
to talk to the president
of the Federal Reserve Bank of Minneapolis
I have to put on a button shirt
but I still have my jogging pants on,
but yes there might be
another structural change.
There's a question here
from YouTube on Chalk Day
and I'll ask the question,
I'll extend it a little bit.
Should the education system
teach banking at school?
And I'll extent it should there be more
of an emphasis on finance,
personal finance, accounting?
A lot of people if you go
back to the financial crisis
back in 2009, 2010 people described it
to just lack of financial literacy,
people getting over their heads.
Obviously, at Khan Academy
will try to do what we can
but I'm curious your point of
view on Chalk Day's question.
- Absolutely, I think a bigger investment
in financial literacy is just making,
regardless of what your
profession is going to be
you're gonna have to manage
your own personal finances
and find a way to make ends meet
and figure out can I afford this house
or can I afford this car or
even this cell phone plan
that I might be interested in?
The basics of financial literacy
I think is really important
and just leaving it to people,
what do we do right now?
For the vast majority
of people we just say,
well you'll kind of
figure it out as you go,
but then when you make mistakes
and you damage your credit
it can be very hard to recover from that
and then your interest rates are higher
and then it makes it more likely
that you're gonna run
into financial problems.
So I think we'd all be better off
if people had the basic skills
they needed at the front end
so they don't have to kind
of learn by making mistakes.
- Yeah, completely, completely agree
and we're happy, we should figure out
how we can work together
to make that a reality.
Another great question from YouTube
Christina Espinoza,
what advice do you have
for teenagers who saw the GameStop event
and wanna take advantage
of stock slash investing?
What do children need to know?
So I have an opinion there as well
I know you are a former investment banker.
I used to work at it as an
analyst at a hedge fund.
So I definitely have a point of view,
but yeah, what would you
tell to Christina about,
well I'm just curious,
what's your point of
view on the whole event?
Is that, do you think this
is just gonna pass us by
or do you think this
will lead to some form
of structural change in some way?
And then what advice would you have
for teenagers who are looking
to get into finance or invest?
- Well, I think what you're
seeing in the markets
with these individual stocks like GameStop
I would just call it a gamble.
It's one group of speculators
that's battling another group
of speculators in a test of wills,
and my basic view on that is,
that's their right, God bless them,
let them do what they want and
if they make money, terrific,
if they lose money, that's
their fault and that's on them
and nobody needs to take
care of them for that.
So they need to go into it eyes wide open,
but to the teenager asking a question,
that's gambling, it is rolling the dice
and when, if you go to Vegas
and I used to go to Vegas
when I was a lot younger, you
go to Vegas with some money
in your pocket, you gotta
be prepared to walk away
and lose it all 'cause that's
what's possibly what could happen.
If you're serious about
getting into investing
you should study it.
You should take some
classes, go to go to college
or community college take
some finance classes,
some banking classes
and you can learn about
how financial markets work so
that you're not just blindly
so that you're not just blindly gambling.
What we're seeing right now,
is just gambling in the markets
and it might work out for some,
it's not going to work
out for most people.
- Yep, and I just wanna add,
I a hundred percent agree
with everything you just said,
as someone who used to work
in the investment world
I can tell you that when it comes
to individual stock picking
there's many very smart people
who are doing a lot of research
and still is a very hard job.
And I remember my old
boss used to tell me,
anytime you think you have
a good investment idea
when you're buying a stock,
someone else is selling that stock to you,
so you've got to believe that
you know something that they don't.
And I do encourage anyone of any age
but especially young people,
put some small amount
of money into the stock market if you can
and you will learn this lesson (laughs)
that the market is a lot harder
and the other people on
the side of the trade
are probably more sophisticated
than you might guess,
and it's so completely agree with you Neel
that it is very speculative.
Now there could be something
about accumulating capital
have a ding of diversified
portfolio over time
that could be something to look into
or if you wanna become a professional
as an investment manager.
Yeah, do your research
and do your homework
and learn to invest the right way
not just speculation, but yeah--
- It is [Indistinct].
So for example, I don't
own any individual stocks,
I own index funds so I do have
exposure to the stock market
and the bond market, but
I'm not sitting here saying
I'd have to spend my
whole day and night trying
to do research to compete
with the professionals
who are literally spending all day
and all night doing that research.
- Yeah, I'll just add to that
I used to my day job for
seven years was an analyst
at Hedge fund where all we
did is essentially pick stocks
and like you, my 401k I have it
in some diversified mutual funds
but I own no individual
stocks right now (laughs)
all of our savings I bought
some rental properties
(laughs) that my say.
So I completely agree with you,
it's a very hard game to
pick individual, individual,
individual stocks for things like that.
One question that I like to ask guests,
because we could talk
about the economy all day
and I have a ton of questions there
but also just wanna understand
your personal journey
to how you got there, cause I don't think,
I'm guessing when you were 15 years old,
you didn't say oh my
career is going to be,
I'm going to be president of
the Federal Reserve Bank of Minneapolis,
and I know there's a lot of young people
who are constantly like what
should I do with my life?
How do I have an impact?
So what was your journey like?
What did you think you were going to be
when you were a teenager?
And then how did that evolve?
How did you end up where you are?
- Well, I went to college and I studied
mechanical engineering at
the university of Illinois.
And the reason I went
to engineering school
is 'cause as a kid I always loved math
and science and physics
and building things
so engineering seemed like an
obvious place for me to go.
I did my bachelor's and
master's in engineering,
and then I went into aerospace
and started developing
technology for NASA.
I went there because to me
working on NASA space center
was as exciting as
challenging as it could be,
and so I learned a ton and I
loved it, but I also realized
that my managers wanted me to get my PhD.
In which case I'd really be committing
to a career in research.
I wasn't ready to do that
so I decided to go back
to business school to learn
about business and finance,
that led me to banking.
Then I went to the US treasury department
and I've had a lot of twists and turns.
The one common thread for
me is I always pursue things
I'm really interested in
that I think are important
that I think are challenging.
And if I'm really challenged
and I'm interested I'll
end up doing my best
and that'll lead to hopefully
lead me to be successful
and that's been true so far.
So there's been no plan,
I've done a variety of different things.
The longest job I've
ever had is now here at
the Minneapolis Fed for five years
and I'm excited I just got reappointed,
so I'll be staying around,
which I'm excited about.
But I guess my message is pursue things
you're genuinely interested
in and life is long
your first job does not
have to be your last job.
Sal as you said you were an analyst
at a Hedge fund for seven years.
I bet along the way you never dreamt
that you'd be running
this a not-for-profit
educating millions of
people around the world.
- I had a lot of daydreams,
some of which came true.
(laughing)
Some of my--
(Neel Kashkari mumbling)
- Yeah, I still have my
whole singer songwriter
folk music career has still
not gotten off the ground,
so it's all one platform onto the next
but yeah, I couldn't agree
more with that narrative.
I am curious and this might be part
of your distant memory now
but you definitely came first
on my radar back in 2010
when it looked like the financial system
was kind of seizing in some way,
you were working for secretary
of treasury, Hank Paulson
at the time to really think about how
to unstick the economy is the
best way I can interpret it.
But I do have to say when it was happening
as much as I wanted the
economy to get unstuck
I was also like, wow,
there's a lot of actors
who did a lot of things that were shady.
You had the ratings
agencies that were approving
putting a high rating on
sliced and diced securities
that were questionable in value
and you had all these incentives.
I think most of us even though
I now run a not-for-profit
and you run a semi-quasi
independent government institution
I would say we both arguably
believe in free markets
and part of the best corrective force
on free markets is kind of you deal
with the consequences of your actions.
And so back in 2010 when a lot
of these banks were kind of
at the cusp of failing
because they'd argue
they had taken on more
risk than they shouldn't.
How did you all think about that?
I used to say, yeah, I get you
need to keep the banks kind
of going so the economy doesn't cease
but what if you were to take the shares
and kind of go through a
controlled bankruptcy process
and distribute them to
the people of America
so it stays private.
What were the conversations back then?
Around stuff like that?
- Yeah, we had those conversations
and it was terrifying,
and the fear that we had was that
if the banking system collapsed
and we'd have that justice moment,
shareholder would get wiped
out, the banks would collapse.
People said it was like a
forest fire, let the fire rage
and then the next season,
new saplings emerge.
And what I always point
out is that may be true
but then all the animals will die
and so what are the consequences
to the American people who did
not cause the banking crisis
if the US banking system
were allowed to collapse.
The great depression
we had 25% unemployment
in the great recession,
even though we did all
of this massive intervention,
treasury Congress, the Fed,
we still had 10% unemployment.
So it was still a devastating crisis,
and so I don't think letting it all fail
was a reasonable thing
to do because the cost
would have been born
by the American people
not just those on wall street.
Having said that, I've
been a strong advocate
since I joined the Minneapolis
Fed that we need to do
a lot more to make sure
that can never happen again.
And we need much stronger
regulations on the biggest banks
so that they don't have risk
of bringing down the US economy again,
and we have not done enough yet.
- Neel, I've actually come
around to that back in 2009, 2010
I had a much more principled view
that like, deal with the consequences
or control the consequences
and figure out something
that on a principle level.
But I think you're
right, history has shown
that what could have led us
into the next great depression
those 10 years were actually a period
of actually quite good economic growth
that frankly if COVID didn't happen,
we would have still been on that curve
that started back in 2010.
So, I've come around to the fact that
I think y'all probably did save
the economy (laughs) in that timeframe,
and honestly the country
owes y'all for that
'cause I can imagine
what has been through.
Just in the remaining time that we have,
I just kinda open it up to you,
any advice you have for folks on,
they're trying to form a view
on the economy, on the world
or just on what to do with their life,
where we have people of all
ages watching us right now.
What advice would you have?
- Well, first thing, get vaccinated
as soon as you're eligible.
I know as soon as my turn becomes,
I'm 47 years old, I'm not
planning not to get a vaccine
for a couple more months but
as soon as it's available,
I'm gonna get vaccinated.
The best thing we can do
to get our economy reopened
is to vaccinate the vast
majority of Americans,
starting with those who are highest risk
but everybody else matters too
because we could still get sick,
we could still spread the virus
and so that's so important
for the economic recovery.
My mom has been vaccinated, my sister,
my cousins they're doctors,
they've been vaccinated.
I'm waiting for my turn,
so that's number one.
Number two, and I just
applaud you for tuning in
into this video call, or this podcast.
Education is so important,
it's been so important
to my life and my success
and in our economy education
is only becoming more important.
It's important to continue
to improve your skills,
continue to get new skills,
and so keep investing in
yourself to get more skills
and more education.
Education is the key
to unlocking opportunity in our country.
It is the best tool we have
to equalize our society
and we know it, and the reason
I'm so passionate about education,
if people get a good education
that's the most powerful tool
we have to break the cycle of poverty.
And so Sal, I really applaud what you
and your colleagues at the
Khan Academy are doing.
And I would just encourage all
of your viewers to be part of
that process, invest in themselves,
invest in their families
and the whole country
will be better off for it.
- Well, I could agree
more about the vaccination
and the education side of things,
and in my household my
wife is a physician,
so she got vaccinated.
My mother-in-law who's at
risk needs a second dose
but I'm now the missing link
but I completely agree with that,
and Neel thank you so much for joining us,
so many questions have been coming in
I apologize for not being able to get
to a lot of them for everyone watching.
But this was a real treat not only
to understand the economy
a little bit better
but also to understand your life journey
and I think it gives everyone confidence
that there's some really
good people trying to do
a good for the world in our government
and our financial system.
So, thank you so much.
- Thank you Sal, it is a
lot of fun, I appreciate it.
- Thanks.
So thank you everyone for joining,
hopefully you enjoyed that conversation
and I do encourage you there's a lot
of questions that came in,
there is one from Adrian Hemmer CEO,
talking about where to invest
money and things like that.
We actually do have a lot
of content on Khan Academy
on both personal finance and on finance
and capital markets generally.
So if you're a young person,
or if you're the parent of a young person,
and watch that stuff
together because frankly,
a lot of adults, most adults
don't understand exactly
how all of that works.
And so once you understand that,
I'd also recommend you can
get a stock simulators,
a lot of people are asking how
to learn about stock investing
and things like that.
You can play with fake money initially
and see how you can perform,
but if you have some money saved up $500
a thousand dollars that could
be a really good education
to kind of see, to start
learning about investing
and putting it to work
and seeing what works
and what doesn't work
I think is a good way
to start learning about money.
But anyway, I'll stop there,
this is going to be our only
live stream for this week.
We we're gonna get a
little bit more regular
over the weeks to come,
I know we've had a few hiatuses.
I don't know if that's the
plural of hiatus, hiatui
but I will see all next week.
So see you all soon,
thanks for joining us.